président de la commission madame le
rapporteur général je ne voudrais
surtout pas monsieur le Président me
prononcer sur les rappels règlement et
laisser croire que je me substituerai
votre autorité pour la police de
l'assemblée de nos débats mais sur le
fond puisque j'ai été interpellé
peut-être faire trois remarques avant
d'aller à la réponse la première
remarque mais je l'ai fait avec le
sourire c'est que vous m'interrogez
toutes et tous sur un document resté
secret donc vous connaissez la teneur
c'est la particularité en renvoyant
parfois
à des brèves rapportés par année
hebdomadaire satirique mais ça fait
partie du débat la deuxième chose pour
dire que une partie de la réponse est
dans la question que vous avez posée sur
une décision orale il a été décidé en
2015 et si on râle du président de la
République de rendre public les avis
concernant les projets de loi ordinaire
cela ne concerne pas vous l'avez dit
vous-même à plusieurs reprises ni les
projets de loi de finance ni les projets
de finance rectificatif ni les projets
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et il n'est pas de mon autorité
de changer règles puisque cette règle a
été fixée par le Président de la
République précédent et je ne me
atteindrai pas de telles décisions
troisième remarque lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale comme d'un projet de
loi de finance le Conseil d'État ne rend
pas d'avis il remet au gouvernement et
en l'occurrence au secrétariat général
du Gouvernement une note de synthèse
cette note de synthèse n'est pas un avis
je le répète et les remise de satariat
général du gouvernement il se trouve
qu'un certain nombre de parlementaires
par les fonctions qu'ils exercent
peuvent si le souhaitent demander à
consulter cette note auprès du
secrétariat général du gouvernement dans
des conditions prévues par celui-ci
voilà la réponse que je pourrais faire
mais c'est le Président et Madame voul